voilà enfin l'info numéro une du jour
c'est encore le documentaire living
neverland a été difficile encore
polémique depuis sa fusion il ya encore
des polémiques sur ce documentaire sur
michael jackson regardée
après de nombreux mois d'une polémique
acharnée autour du documentaire living
neverland la chaîne edge bio a enfin
diffusée dimanche et lundi sur son
antenne ce programme qui revient sur les
accusations de pédophilie au tour de
michael jackson au programme de ce
documentaire une séquence choc dans
laquelle un homme raconte que michael
jackson aurait organisé un faux mariage
avec un enfant de 10 ans de son côté
jackie lombard la productrice française
de l'artiste ne crois pas du tout aux
accusations concernant le roi de la pop
qu'elle a très bien connu
un avis que partage la famille du
chanteur qui est très remonté suite à la
diffusion de ce documentaire événement
si dans un premier temps les proches du
chanteur ont intenté une action en
justice qui pour le moment n'a pas été
officialisée dans un second temps ils
ont essayé de discréditer dans la presse
le récit des deux victimes qui témoigne
dans le documentaire
en suite à la diffusion de ce
documentaire qui fait parler dans le
monde entier la chaîne de radio bbc
aurait décidé de ne plus diffuser aucun
titre du roi de la pop une polémique
n'est pas prête de s'éteindre puisque le
documentaire va être diffusé très
prochainement dans de nombreux pays et
notamment en france sur m6 le 21 mars
prochain
michael jackson alors on vous l'a dit ça
va être diffusée sur m6 c'est vrai que
ça n'arrête pas les polémiques du oui
non je trouve qu'il ya un tel débat
avant la diffusion que je sais pas ce
qui va rester après si ça mais je vous
dis on n'a jamais vu ça je veux dire un
débat mondial international et moi ce
qui me chagrine
je n'ai pas encore vu non plus de
documentaires non mais c'est juste le
fait qu' il est mort depuis quelques
temps depuis longtemps déjà
non je dire on aurait pu sortir beaucoup
de polémiques des documentaires avant
sur la base de la vérité mais la vérité
après la mort ça me gêne toujours un
petit peu à la fadeur pour la vérité sur
le bâton de berger
oui les fans de michael jackson ont
appelé au boycott des chaînes qui
diffusent qui ont acheté le document
sert donc étudie donc étudier aux états
unis
chanel fort pour l'angleterre et m6 pour
la pour la france en dix ans alors je
vous dis ils sont même prévus un truc je
vous jure que c'est vrai il paraît que
les fans de michael jackson
il paraît que ils vont faire un truc le
soir de la diffusion il paraît que quand
vous allez prendre votre télécommande
jure que c'est vrai c'est rassurant si
vous appuyez sur la cité faire il va ya
une décharge en fait voilà qui bâtit pas
non sur la polenta le lie à retardement
oui la polémique va arriver en france et
à ce que les fans de michael jackson
commence à mettre la pression sur m6
cette fois ils dénoncent un documentaire
diffamatoire à bien des égards la peine
at war on n'exclut pas une action en
justice à paris
moi je me prononce pas sur la véracité
des faits est évidemment m'enfin dans ce
genre d'affaires c'est pas la famille ni
aux fans coûte banide est le plus jeune
est d'accord il nous faut la bei donné
l'info et voilà merci oui mais c'est
juste qu'on on tombe des nues mais on
les connaît les accusations de
pédophilie sommeil mais bon 93 avait
déjà eu un adolescent on sait qu'il a
fait une sorte d'accord à l'amiable avec
la famille 20 millions de dollars fait
partie du barreau non mais c'est là la
honte je vous dire d'abord la famille
vient d'attaquer hier soir ils attaquent
h bio à lacets leur réclame 100 millions
de dollars ben oui autrement les deux
garçons qui à l'époque lors du procès
avait dit il n'y a pas eu la tâche mans
rien du tout c'est un mec bien et c sont
eux maintenant que tu as changé en
trente neuf ans qui eux se remettent à
attaquer à dire des horreurs dans le
documentaire
vous défendez toujours les gens célèbres
vous c'est populaire s'élève vous êtes
du côté employé du côté du peuple des
gens qui peut-être ont été victimes de
compass mélangez pas tout je mélange pas
tout non ils ont dit à l'époque c'était
pas vrai c'est vrai ce mardi a eu des
pressions vous le savez très bien
il est du côté de son rôle du côté des
people toujours mais non mais c'est
gonflant à fort et responsable il sera
de votre côté
abdallah ii le robinson et en irlande à
votre ami à quel prix alors on a alors
là moi on va reconstruire le début allez
on y va comment tu te mets là vous allez
nous on la reprend cette ville ouais
c'est michael jackson qui nous appellent
donc je vous appelle de paris boulogne
oui bonjour je vous entends très bien
mais vu cela une telle dérogation la
tâche tu as khroub à la propriété et que
jackson est en vente c'était neverland
ces familles par l'attraction donner un
prix de la vente et frère tu m'as pris
pour stéphane plaza et vous avez une
idée pour ça mais combien il faut de
mètres carrés témoin qui aurait fait
deux mètres carrés culte et plusieurs
bah ouais mais deux mois des infos ferme
au cinquième si tu mets sur une âme au
vent un appart dumont j'ai pas le nombre
de clés non il ya trop de fignon trop
mignon 69 millions 69 millions à basse
et jean michel lalonde à merci voilà
merci bas on va voir et on peut la voir
1 1 29 euro est possible mais peu
ric-rac l'asie endroit sympa je vous lis
attendra pas ça j'ai loupé pour la libye